nando honest trailers reaction for the
mandalorian season one
season two comes out this week we will
be covering it reaction highlights will
be up here on the youtube channel first
episode
will probably be up either saturday
halloween or sunday november 1st sorry
if it's a couple days late hit that
subscribe button notification bell just
in case any who it's honest trailers
baby let's check it out
this episode is sponsored by state farm
after star wars was ruined forever
thanks to the monsters at disney
star wars will be unruly by an all-new
streaming series
made by the monsters at disney i'm
confused do they hate us or not
this is the way depends who's in charge
anakin was supposed to bring balance
and ray just ended up squatting at the
farm of her mentor's uncle that he hated
and couldn't wait to run away from
sorry sorry not today episode 9 now
one food truck enthusiast will rise
revitalize the franchise in his vr
garage
and keep the empire in business
they got the families over a muppet baby
kathleen kennedy more like crappily and
keen oh
aka bando which starts to sound like a
slur the more you hear it
hey hand over the child man though
actual wandering yep
hey man it's a western it's a very
soothing montage
as he jets from exotic locales to less
exotic locales
to a quick detour to lost nostalgia
typically
nostalgia
but screw it how fun is it to dick
around in the star wars universe without
some sad kid in their daddy is just
killing the butt
everything i mean he's got some parent
issues not a gun gunman
meets the most adorable mcguffin of all
time
the child okay you know what we're not
doing that he's a baby
he's baby
she's got a kink fetish man he's not
nearly as precocious when they reveal
he's
actually a middle-aged man they said 50
years old
i'm on you baby yoda you can talk you're
just some creepy brewer with a diaper
fetish aren't you
the likes of which you've never seen
before but don't freak out
look the linear stuff tatooine classic
stormtroopers
good breathe
to clear an extremely low bar be
the best single dad in star wars but
this father-son duo won't travel alone
there's queer who finally gave a modern
update to talk to the hand
i have spoken i have spoken
to buy a student's acting coach you take
this home throwing the pot
some broth the potato you turn still
going
and cara dude the ex-rebel with less
range than the guy in the helmet
so we're going to build a trap perfect
for gina carol we're going to need to
dig real deep
right here but when it steps in it drops
together they'll encounter scum villainy
and the best alternate dimension cast of
saturday night live
with horatio sands
brian hussein amy cedaris
bill bird that's a that's a great one
john
tom haley's voice is on par
there you go damage to your central
processing unit
you mean my brain
who just wanted to know why baby yoda
was on your kid's christmas list but
stuck around because it reminded you of
the searchers
a casual fan who spent eight episodes
wondering why luke skywalker wasn't
validation for keeping your toy
collection all these years
wait is that the imperial true transport
it's beautiful that owes its success to
telling a simple lean story it was
pretty damn good
and because it was a hit i was probably
about to weigh it down with a bunch of
lower crossovers and spin-offs
this is the way starring
dark helmet 9 50.
baby you've got a rootley stew going
but death and chaos
i would like to see the baby yes again
i'm sorry sir you sounded like someone
else little babysitter gloves
shut your mouth cause i have spoken
the outer skyrim i like them huh
boba feed let's make the bacon do the
magic hands
come on baby do the magic hand thing
that's not how it matters
everything works nerds at the round
table
and when my friends ask what fastball
song we're listening to
this is
is a mostly mechanic bounty hunting and
cantina-centric economy
no one's ever a real estate agent in
these things marketing somehow the star
wars universe remains dentist free
don't they have teeth do you know your
ig-11s from your k2s host that you
should play
it's a good amount of money this episode
is sponsored by state there's so many
agents at state farms
so many agents i'm a mandalorian weapons
are part of my religion this is the way
i have spoken i'm curvy and i like it
hey ah that's job of the hudson oh
i don't know if this is the first for
honest trailers i doubt it is but they
had
two two different castles read-offs here
because they had their you know usual
making fun of people's names like uh
werder herzog as himself but then they
had that snl bit
which i wasn't catching on to right away
like horatio i'm like okay just cause
ratio of santa i realized oh yeah
there's a whole thing about
so many comedians that were appearing
throughout that season so much and the
bits and the graphics and john bailey's
voice combined with that hilariously
done
i thought this was a really great honest
trailers because it had kind of the new
wave of honest trailer voice which what
is more like observational commentary
combined with some really great jokes
as well you know like the this is like a
six and a half minute version you're
covering a whole season to television
but there were so many
wonderful things pointed out here i love
the jokes especially about yeah
there's so much nostalgia crammed in
here so much for
people in the know the childhood with
the toys and things that like we didn't
even pick up on
all this like extended lore but then
also the idea of
someone who's just a casual viewer who's
tuning in who's like where's luke
skywalker i don't understand what the
hell is happening right now
why are we focusing on this guy in
specific yeah this honest trailer really
made me appreciate especially the way
these are
written and also i just love the way
that this led with yeah
capturing how strange fractured and
almost
ironic the star wars fan base has come
especially under the rule of disney
who's brought some of the most hated and
now one of the most
loved since the originals installments
of star wars yeah yeah yeah and i love
that crack about the whole
single dad joke being the best single
dad in the universe i got disagree about
the parental issues though while we
don't hear too much about binjar and
having
you know daddy issues necessarily i mean
he did lose his parents when he was a
child
exactly yeah you know battle and
speaking a child i love that crack that
they make about meet the child
and no no this is called baby because
there was that whole thing i remember
when bob iger was on i think it was on
jimmy kimmel and
he was talking about how he went back
and forth with john favreau and he was
calling him baby yoda bob iger was and
then john favreau was like that's not
his name and like bob iger and john
favreau know the child's real name but
come on let's face it it's the same way
how we call
mando mando you know the whole thing
about that being a slur
yeah that was great too i never even
picked up i never thought of that i'm
like you know what there is something to
that
because how you say it yeah just a
slight way in the tone
yeah exactly and i never looked at it as
some type of derogatory way of saying it
just based off of the tone
with baby yoda let's face it even when
we learn
baby yoda's real name we've been calling
him baby yoda for such a long time we're
gonna just keep on calling him baby yoda
i don't think that's ever gonna change
people in the know who really remember
mandalorian season one we'll
we'll call him denjarin but everyone
really refers to him as the mandalorian
orlando
baby is the bedrock of us understanding
who this character is and any name they
slap
on top of it we might remember but we'll
always revert subconsciously yeah baby
and it's perfect too i think this is
really crisp because like as a
show it is a full series but also
they're shorter episodes so like it
lends itself to an honest trailer in the
sense that you do get enough
episodic things to pull broadly from but
also
one pretty simple story at the end of
the day
overall satirize in a trailer format
even though it is a large breadth of
story
this actually feels like one really
coherent trailer yeah it doesn't feel
like i'm jumping
wildly through a season or anything yeah
yeah
and i did not realize how many times
they did say this is the way like oh
they said it a little bit more than i
realized i did
yeah a little bit more i have spoken i
mean i've spoken i noticed that
like you kind of counted on your own one
two hands at least how many times that
said
but this is the way i was like oh
there's that way more than i realized
anyway honest trailers thanks for
putting this together screen
junkies miss you guys subscribe to
screen jugglers if you haven't done so
already subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction from the
mandalorian is up like i said it'll
either be saturday or sunday
catch you guys soon hit the like button
blah blah blah